and how did you get good like when did
you go from suck to non-suck like
because everybody starts i believe that
suck that's like the pixar way i don't
know if you've heard this before pixar
is a philosophy which is all movies
start at suck our job is to like remove
the suck yeah so there's non-suck left
at the end yeah
yeah so i took that approach man the
daily show changed my life man seeing
the way jon stewart worked and
especially that institution
both daily show and snl love them hate
them they're part of their comedy
institutions
snl for 50 years
now a daily show 25
you know that
um
are
these pedigree boot camps for
understanding the process about how to
think about comedy right and one of the
things that i realized is what john
taught me and trevor showed me
you know john really unlocked the code
but it's like it's all about your take
what is your take and being able to back
it up so it's not even being funny first
it's what is the take what am i trying
to say what is the take what am i
philosophically artistically trying to
say
and
um let's give an example you had in the
show last night you're like you met this
guy who's a private equity guy you're
like what the is that yeah he's
like oh yeah we do like lbos you're like
yeah
yeah what is the leverage we'll
as you get to the bottom of your like so
you use other people's money to buy
other people's companies and you ruin
the people's lives in them by firing
them and gutting them making them
profitable and then you flip it to
somebody else yeah you're like yeah i'm
not cool with that like yeah i think
that's a little bit of a up way
to win is to like yeah this is kind of
like vulture just legal stealing yeah
yeah yeah yeah
that was never your money
yeah
also it's it's it's stealing well it's
legal oh just just because legal doesn't
mean it's ethical right you know bill
cosby got off legally right we all know
what it is
and so like that is what the joke i
would start with that's my take around
leverage buyouts and vulture funds right
then you start tagging it you can do
that bill cosby tag he got off legally
it's not right you know we all know it's
on ethical what he did or whatever the
glove didn't fit o.j yeah
right
right so you must go ahead okay
um
and then you start tagging and then the
funny just starts flowing from there and
then you go that's like this and then
you can just what are you doing you're
sitting in a room with like a few people
you're just spitballing riffing
bantering just like that yeah and then
eventually you got to put pen to paper
right and you got to start writing the
act one and you start to see when i
watch weekend update or when i see an
act one on the daily show or any of
those desk segments i now see the matrix
i now see oh i know how to construct a
seven and a half minute piece right last
week tonight patriot act i know how to
do a 27 minute piece on it right i know
the beats and the flow of that and what
was really cool was it just gave me that
um
that central kind of like philosophy how
do i do this
and so the first 10 11 12 years of my
career i was just trying to be funny
and what john in 2014 really helped me
unlock was like no no you need to have
like um
there needs to be an actual process and
purpose to what you do now i'm not
saying this as a virtue thing no just
you just need to be like even if you're
doing dick jokes or even if you're being
silly
there needs to be you need to understand
the game and how to heighten it
comedically right even stupid silly
jokes you know are are like that and so
um
that was the unlock for me and then just
reps trying to get as good as possible
now my my next thing that i'm just
working on the most
is the jazz part of it like yo just have
fun that's always been one of my
weaknesses because like i told you like
i'm a kumon kid you're structured and so
and so we're so built around fear
and so there's these moments
that i try to have on stage i don't know
if you saw us it's like i'm just kind of
unhinged like
the first like three or four minutes of
the set when i'm just i'm literally just
riffing yeah when i was making fun of
the kids shorts there was a kid in the
front row of the show just short shorts
yeah
the eyes were just like all up on the
chair and then like the seats in the
back and you know seeing people come in
late and then riffing off of that it's
pure jazz now jazz has structure but
there's also play right and then you can
go back
to it and like it's that organized chaos
that i'm trying to like start to tap
into